ein herzliches willkommen und grüß gott
heute wieder aus der maria theresien
kaserne
wir sind heute für euch da mit einem
theraband workout für den oberkörper
gestern haben wir noch die beine
belastet heute der oberkörper und morgen
gehen wir dann in eine auszeit bewegung
in eine ausdauerbelastung hinein das
theraband an sich ist ja sehr gutes
trainingsmittel
um gerade in den zeiten wie jetzt wo man
kein fitnessstudio besuchen kann oder
entsprechend vielleicht zu hause keine
gewichte hat japan das immer klar
eingesteckt aber widerstandsband
wunderkammer gute übungen machen und wir
zeigen euch das jetzt heute wie man das
am besten mit dem oberkörper kombiniert
der mangel ist da die nici ist da ich
der beta bin da wir führen euch durch
das programm
macht euch bereit denn jetzt mit und wir
beginnen mit aufwärmen das heißt
lockeres laufen am stand gleich wieder
ein kniehoher mal ein barren links
rechts nach vorne
anschließend hinten
[Applaus]
und auch bekannt der boxer live gleich
wieder dazu ein baum
auch hier können sie immer wieder ein
kniehoch mit einbauen wird dann schon
qualitativ aber schwieriger muss man
schon nachdenken was man tut
[Applaus]
wir bringen gemeinsam den kreislauf ein
bisschen schwung wir bereiten euch für
das training vor kurzem aus lockern wir
beginnen aber wieder es zu mobilisieren
sprunggelenk manchmal kleine ein
weinstand sprunggelenk kreisen dass man
das gleichgewicht dann aber bisher
fordern
das nehme mit und in die andere richtung
drehen seite wechseln andere seite
ok mit einmal abstellen pappeln
einspringen
auch hier kann man natürlich kleine
kreative aspekte mit einbauen dass man
zum beispiel einmal wechselt das nicht
immer die hand oben geschlossen ist
während ein grätsche da ist sondern dass
man wechselt das heißt die hand ist
unten geschlossen mit den beinen der
keine einfach mich selbst das spiel und
da hin und her wechseln oder nach vorn
zurück der wechsel mit schritten genau
[Applaus]
wichtig ist dass wir uns bewegen dass
man den kreislauf eben wie gesagt
ankurbeln und entsprechenden uns für das
training vorbereiten aus lockern
kurz durchschütteln ich weiß nicht wie
es euch geht das programm gestern
durchtrainiert mit den beinen ich spiele
meine beine ganz schön
das heißt wir müssen natürlich auch
schauen dass man da bislang in die
muskulatur wieder reinbringen dass man
da vielleicht auch in der regeneration
gleich bei den beinen hatte sowas
mitmachen
okay aber vorwärts kreiseln schöne
mobilität aus der schulter wieder
arbeiten
eine rückwärts kreisen eine nach vor und
einer zurück richtung wechseln
richtung wechseln das kriegt ja wieder
qualitative komponente wenn man öfter
sind schnell die richtung wechselt
wechsel
wechsel wechsel und ausschütteln aus
sorg anblick wendung linke seite rechte
seite als visuelle wir wärmen den
oberkörper mit auf wenn man die
natürlich danach mit dem theraband
entsprechend belasten kopf nach oben und
nach unten
die linke seite rechte seite kippen
und wir machen wieder halbkreise rechte
seite auf die linke seite und umgekehrt
wir wollen das kind quasi über die brust
auf die andere seite
okay wir gehen denn die bewegung wir
machen gerne stadtlauf mit anführer sind
gern einen anfangs- und kurzes anfassen
selbständiger kurz das tempo steigern
wieder langsamer werden wieder schneller
werden
und kurz durch lockern ausschütteln
oberkörper verdrehen linke seite rechte
seite händen im zuger schwungmasse mit
mobilisieren und aufwärmen gelenke
vorbereiten muskulatur vorbereiten dass
dann die wichtigen dinge die man jetzt
umsetzen müssen jetzt einmal rotation
gelang durch interviewer säule zu machen
wir gleich eine belastung die bisserl
weniger rotation ist sondern mir
mobilisation das heißt in den
vierfüßlerstand bitte die knie gehen
soll am boden lassen in eine rundrücken
position dass der klassische
katzenbuckel und durchdrücken in dem
pferderücken gerne 45 mal hin und her
wechseln
und wenn man schon in der position sein
wenn man schon draußen aktivieren mal
gleich auch die rumpfmuskulatur
das heißt linkes bein rechte hand
strecken unter dem körper dann zusammen
fahren das heißt ausstrecken und
schließen dreimal linke seite 123 und
dreimal rechte seite eins zwei und drei
und da stehen wir gleich wieder auf und
bewegen wir uns wieder einmal dass
anfänge sind gemacht die hebel auf
lockerer knie hebel auf geht's los
auch hier kann man das tempo wieder
variieren kurz schneller werden
langsamer werden selbständig wechseln
einmal noch schneller gehen und wieder
ausloggen das anstrengende varianten zum
aufwärmen dass man wie gesagt wirklich
den körper in schwung bringen gott sei
dann schauen wir noch für die oberen
extremität brustmuskel bewegung denen in
einer dynamik elten hochelten
zurückziehen arme aufmachen zurückziehen
und im wechsel zweimal kurz zweimal lang
das brauchen wir danach die bewegung her
mit dem theraband dann lass mir gleich
die eltern hoch in der statischen
position und kreis meinem unterarm
durchschnaufen weiteratmen er ganz
wichtig richtung wechseln
genau hände falten quasi zusammen
handgelenke kreisen andere richtung und
ein bisserl freundlich schauen dass sie
die leute nicht fürchten daher genau
sehr gut und auslagern
was dann bewegen wir haben wir ganz kurz
aber in der position liegestütze
ausstellung das heißt was haben wir
kommen warten klein war richtig erkannt
genau und geht's los
[Applaus]
sie konnten fünf vier drei zwei eins und
wieder aufstehen und aussagen
nachdem er jetzt eine kraft belastung
haben ja müssen wir natürlich auch
unsere muskeln entsprechend vorbereiten
das heißt wir bauen keine 1 4 x 7
das heißt sieben liegestützen kniebeugen
7 6 und 7 brücken aufrichten geht's los
einerseits bereit man das herz
kreislaufsystem vorher mit der bewegung
das mobilisieren für die gelenke und der
muskulatur natürlich am besten mit einer
übung und das an die klassischen übungen
liegestütz kniebeuge sieht ab und rücken
aufrichten natürlich gute variante
nummer zwei aber dann gehen wir gleich
mit ab
und wie gesagt wenn ihr mit dabei sein
wenn ihr euch bescheid aufwärmt
hauptsache überhaupt kein problem
intensives krafttraining ein workout mit
dem theraband damit zu machen sodass
rechnet verletzt und das maximum
herausholen könnte aus dem workout da
wichtig nicht druckreifen mit der kraft
arbeiten gleich armatur aufstehen aus
lockern
hier gibt es bereits
mal bei dir passt da dann wenig
veranschlagen wir starten mit der ersten
übung das heißt den facebook macht uns
das bitte klären vor knapp der wand
hängt so seien ungefähr auf schulterhöhe
schaut hin zum fixpunkt in dem fall
unsere stange album hoch auf
schulterhöhe und sieht es die ellbogen
zurück muss man schauen dass man da kein
knoten in den bändern trainern haben
genau jeder ist ein richtiges ende hat
dass das scheitern der spannung bleibt
jetzt als position ellbogen hoch
stabiler rücken und zurückziehen
genau das kann sogar in einer ebene
passieren das heißt ihr habt
schultergelenk ellbogen und in dem fall
die fast auf einer höhe zieht zurück
versucht seinen entspannt der
halswirbelsäule zu haben das den kopf
nicht nach vorzubeugen
gerner und einen schönen zug nach hinten
aufbauen
wir machen das ganze 30 sekunden
und die wird vorschlag jetzt etwa 30
sekunden facebook der bahn zug auf
schulter auf kopfhöhe
wichtig dabei auch stabile position
natürlich aus der rumpfmuskulatur sowie
bei jedem krafttraining das heißt darum
da braucht der rücken bleibt unter
spannung der ist permanent muskulär
fixiert und die arme ziehen zurück 5
sekunden
und 30 sekunden durch kurzausflug kann
merkt euch bitte eure ende und die
zweite übung die man machen ist auch
gleich aus derselben position
jetzt haben wir mal den oberen rücken
mit dabei kommt und natürlich den
gegenspieler den brustmuskel nehmer glas
zweite variante das heißt die schnaps
band dreht euch mit dem rücken zum
fixpunkt wählt eine position wo er den
oberkörper leicht in eine vorlage bringt
genau ist es da ham die seitlich und
dann vor dem körper zusammenziehen
genau das ist die übung das ist die
variante widerstand will zu entweder
theraband doppelt nehmen oder bisschen
weiter weg gehen ja kein problem
30 sekunden haben wir zeit zum üben und
wir starten gleich 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit auch hier wichtig versucht
mit schwung in die bewegung hinein zu
fahren sondern versuche das möglichst
gleichmäßig zu bewegen
alternativ lassen halbzeit ist vorbei
50 konnten
und theraband entspannen das heißt nicht
ruckartig loslassen nicht wegschnappen
lassen sondern einfach langsam die
spannung herausbringen
jetzt haben einer übung die ist ganz
ganz wichtig für sportarten wo ich für
über kopf werfen muss schlagen muss was
er immer das heißt wir haben das schon
mal mit dabei kommt die
rotatorenmanschette die muss man
trainieren
und da gibt es eigentlich kein besseres
trainingsgerät dafür wieso
widerstandsband in dem verein theraband
das heißt die pfosten fixiert punkt
ungefähr auf kopf schulterhöhe geht sie
in eine position ellbogen seitlich nach
oben
und jetzt ganz wichtig für ein quartier
kurz bevor du bewegst die drehachse ist
zwischen ellbogen und schultergelenk das
bleibt stabil und nur der handrücken
genau
der zieht es dort zurück und geht wieder
nach vor und es bleibt stabil
30 sekunden ist richtig anstrengend aber
geht es los
genau und es kam er immer ansprechen
kontrollieren auch hier da stabile der
die aktive position im stehen und ab die
uni passau verbogen und schulter bleibt
fixiert und jetzt dresdner zurück genau
und wenn das nicht geht man nicht
ausweichen müsst geht sabrina hin
dann ist ein bisserl zu viel zug am
theraband drauf dann ist es ein bisserl
zu kräftig gewählt drei sekunden
21 und sommer wieder durch kurz aus
lockern und ausschütteln im geiste
einmal durchgehen wie schaut die übung
zweite herren das gleich klar aber man
fängt meistens mit der besseren seite an
deswegen nur mal probieren einrichten
position finden körperspannung aufbauen
und in fünf sekunden legen wir dann
wieder los mit dem zweiten durchgang
bereitmachen 21 uhr los geht's schön
fixieren wie gesagt ellbogen und
schulter eine drehachse die bleibt und
die hand bewegt sich zurück gm
konzentriert sich darauf ganz wichtige
übung und wie gesagt da im bereich der
rotatorenmanschette ein schultergelenk
richtig stabil zu bekommen
sie konnten
21 uhr und kurz aus lockern
es heißt motto manschette in einer
position schulter hoch bis über kopf
sommer gemacht jetzt gehen wir in dem
bereich wo dann hinein das heißt jetzt
kurz mal dass die ära brand aus der
erhöhten position aushängen und eine
fixierung am boden unten so höhe 20 cm
wäre optimal finden
das heißt wir haben jetzt meine zug
bewegung dabei und die ist ähnlich wie
in der kraftkammer wenn wir zum beispiel
das rudern am tiefen blog r nimmt das
kann ich mit dem theraband ganz gut
simulieren das heißt ich gegen eine
position stabiler muskulär abgesicherte
wirbelsäule herum spannung aufgebaut und
aus dieser position heraus gestreckte
arme ziehe ich jetzt die ellbogen links
und rechts vom körper vorbei in die
rückwärtige position und wieder nach vor
und zurück und vor
das ist die bewegung und so will sie den
widerstand dass sich diese 30 sekunden
wirklich produktiv arbeiten kennst das
ihr aber spürt zum schluss und nicht nur
denkt zwar nett sondern muss es richtig
anstrengend sein
seit läuft 30 sekunden gehts los die
knackpunkte bei der bewegung ist den
rumpf richtig zu spannen und der rücken
bleibt fixiert gerade stabil die
wirbelsäule ist muskulär abgesichert
atmen dabei nicht vergessen einatmen
ausatmen immer in die bewegung nicht
einbauen sekunden sander 5 nach 3 21 und
rudern ist erledigt jetzt noch einmal
mittel aus dem bauch aus dieser position
die japan tief das als schatz das bitte
so ein hängt das entsprechend euch nicht
zu viel nachrutschen kann und erst am
besten ist das entsprechend zu fixieren
bayern stabilen heizungsrohr in der türe
einklemmen wo er immer verschiedene
möglichkeiten genau jetzt aufrichten
theraband seitlich halten
mit einer hand am besten und aus der
aufgerichteten position nur den
oberkörper zur seite ziehen zur seite
kippen wirtschaftskammer vor nicki genau
aus der position aufrecht seit kippen
und dann kriegt die spannung in meine
seitlichen bauchmuskulatur hinein
die seitlichen aber in dem fall mit dem
theraband eine genauso gut variante
manuela stabile position aktiver stand
muskulär abgesichert und das kippen zur
seite zeit läuft 30 sekunden arbeitszeit
geschlossen
und wie gesagt dass theraband an sich
ist natürlich ein trainings equipment
das kann überall hin mitnehmen ja das
geht in jedem koffer in jede reisetasche
das geht ins handgepäck hinein
das kann ja auf urlaub mitnehmen dass
dies immer mit dabei und ich kann jedes
mal mein eigenes kleines fitnessstudio
wo auch immer aufbauen
bereits nach drei sekunden und sei aus
30 sekunden seite wechseln
jetzt sieht es ganz normal aus der
rückansicht das heißt wie schaut es aus
wenn man hinten die wirbelsäule und den
die rückseite wie gesagt betrachtet kurz
wieder einrichten die spannung richtig
wählen
10 sekunden und dann legen wir mit der
zweiten seite arglos noch 5 und arbeiten
auch hier achtet darauf dass sich der
körper nicht verdreht in sicht sondern
sehr schön gerade auf und ab
beziehungsweise in dem fall
links und rechts kommt das heißt nicht
in sich hinein rotieren sondern
seitwärts kippen und wieder aufrichten
genau so ist es zehn sekunden nur dann
ist es auch gleich wieder durch spürbar
seitliche plane
ein wenig spürbar dass das nächste mal
mehr sparen und nehmen dass man mehr
spüren wie ein wenig ok 30 sekunden
durch kurzausflug kann jetzt eine übung
für die holzhacker unter uns nur eine
hacke und nicht von oben nach unten
sondern von unten nach oben bezeichnet
als reverse webshop das machen wir jetzt
gleich das heißt theraband etwas kürzer
nehmen mit viel widerstand beide hände
greifen fester thera band und ihr zieht
quasi die haken die rückwärtige position
hoch genau der kein ruhiger gewisse
rotation auch im oberkörper jetzt
drinnen sein
schöne spannung aufbauen und wie gesagt
immer muskulär das ganze gesichert
rolfes gespannt dass der bau der rücken
und eine dynamische bewegung da heraus
30 sekunden arbeitszeit geht schon los
und natürlich die unter euch die
entsprechend voll fit sein und richtig
richtig gas geben wollen können
natürlich die 30 sekunden
euro verdoppeln eine minute durch
arbeiten und an fliegenden wechsel in
die nächste übung machen das ist
natürlich immer möglich ja sehen
sekunden
321 zeit ist durch seite wechseln
auch hier wieder variante position
gesetzes von hinten was passiert in der
wirbelsäule
wo kommt die rotation hin macht sich
bereit
so passt man nickt ja dann geht's aus 30
sekunden rotation bot rebers kennt ja
immer wieder zwischendrin nachjustieren
wenn die spannung zu viel oder zu wenig
wird vom gefühl her
dann gibt es auch mehr dazu oder eben a
bisserl weniger und auch hier die farbe
des trabants bestimmt natürlich bis zu
einem gewissen grad die intensität das
heißt das beginnt bei gelb grün blau und
geht dann bis gold hinauf ihr wählt sich
das was wir euch am besten ist okay 30
sekunden haben letzte übung die man
machen für die rückenstrecke das heißt
stellt euch zu eurem aufnahme punkt mit
dem rücken hin fehlt die die ära bänder
oder das theraband durch die beine durch
streckte die knie und bewegt den
oberkörper mal in eine tiefe position
und aus der tiefen position hoch und die
handicaps geleitet und mit vornehmen
genau das heißt runter und traf
geraderücken stabil die rückenstrecke
freuen sich die werden jetzt belastet
und legen wir los
30 sekunden arbeitszeit rückenstrecke
gerade im bereich der lendenwirbelsäule
wird jetzt stark mit trainiert als
zweite variante kann es natürlich ein
bisschen an beinarbeit mit hinein nehmen
gestern haben wir die äsche belastet die
beine das heißt wenn ich jetzt an winkel
ins kniegelenk hineinbringen
dann habe natürlich meine strecke das
heißt den oberschenkel und das gesäß
auch noch ein bisschen mit dabei fünf
sekunden
und seit kurzem war das theraband
ablegen einmal schütteln ein bisserl
ausgehen
ein schluck trinken wer möchte halbzeit
trainings halbzeit workout halbzeit
hammer erreicht eine frage fand ich wo
ist das theraband bei dir schon auf der
weltgeschichte mitgereist immer wieder
zwischendrin einmal 20 minuten oder 30
minuten ein kleines werk machen
das ist wichtig und es kann nicht wie
gesagt am strand irgendwo genauso machen
wie überall auf der welt in wahrheit
genau mal bei dir lehrerband ständiger
begleiter oder ja das ist natürlich ein
thema wenn jetzt wirklich intensive
kraft trainingseinheit vor mir habe man
kann das natürlich auch perfekt als auf
wir haben mit einbauen das heißt die ein
oder andere übung die dann vielleicht
mit gewicht in der kraftkammer
absolviert kann ich natürlich mit dem
theraband als warm up perfekt umsetzen
ok wird vorschlagen
wir lassen nicht zu viel zeit
verstreichen wir machen uns bereit für
den zweiten durchgang
30 sekunden noch einmal belasten 30
sekunden pause und wir beginnen wieder
oben
das heißt ihr baut eure station zu hause
so weit um dass sie den zug wieder
zwischen shooter und kopfhöhe ungefähr
aufbaut das heißt die aufnahme von der
band ist jetzt wieder in der oberen
position
die erste übung der facebook
das heißt ihr seid in der position
aufrecht stolzer brust und sieht nach
hinten mit dem ellbogen zurück wir
starten in 10 sekunden und dann geht's
los
30 sekunden dann wieder arbeitszeit oder
auch 60 wenn ihr wollt bereit machen
los geht's
ich kenne ja gerne mal mit zählen wie
viele wiederholungen sie da raus gehen
glaubt nicht du bist bei fünf gerade
sein wir dann war jetzt fünf halbzeit
haben wir schon gut geschafft fünf
sekunden auf 3 212 das aus wie für
wiederholungen als gehabt genau zehn
wiederholungen
also wenn ihr irgendwo in dem bereich 10
12 13 wiederholungen sie in 30 sekunden
dann passt das tempo war ganz gut
deshalb dass kuka pool und seinen
kreisen sondern wirklich mit der kraft
arbeiten position wechseln danke ihr
habt euch gebracht das heißt rücken zu
einer aufnahme vom theraband leichte
schräglage im oberkörper position so
wählen dass sie das thema band auch vor
dem körper dann zusammen ziehen könnt
und euch nicht dabei steige jetzt das
heißt nicht der falsche sondern vor dem
körper so dass im optimalfall das auch
bei der schulter dann drüber läuft zeit
läuft 30 sekunden
spannt den bauch herum spannung ist da
clapper ist stabil in seiner leichten
schräglage dass die wirbelsäule bewegt
jetzt nicht die arme gehen zurück und
noch vor die schultern bleiben tief das
nicht zum wechsel hochziehen die
schulter sondern entsprechend unten
lassen
nach drei sekunden und seit der übung
nummer 2 abgeschlossen
jetzt kann man wieder in eine
rotationsbewegung hinein
rotatorenmanschette schotter wichtig
ellbogen ist hoch und der zug kommt hier
drehachse ein schultergelenk da ist
bewegung drin sondern nur die hand geht
nach hinten best mit dem handrücken im
kopf vorstellen der zieht nach es
bereits los geht's 30 sekunden drehachse
lp schultergelenk mal dass der apple
aufpassen stabil bleiben in der position
genau traf typen eltern blättern bleibt
ja wahr und zurück sind sehr gut 30
sekunden rotatorenmanschette bewegung
wichtig wie gesagt für alle schlag
sportarten wo sie über kopf machen muss
muss die rotatorenmanschette
entsprechend mein schultergelenk
stabilisieren und fixieren sich durch
position wechseln
zweiter hand die spannung wieder richtig
wählen am ausprobieren geht sie das in
30 sekunden dass sie diese spannung
aufrecht erhalte so dass mich auch
gefordert bin sind sie konnten dann
zweite seite nach 3
26 und arbeitszeit läuft auch hier
entspannt den kopf gerade aus kopf ist
immer in verlängerung der wirbelsäule
hier beim training aktive spannung aus
der rumpfmuskulatur der bauch ist unter
zug der rücken ist gespannt und in dem
verarbeitet nur die hand achtet auf die
drehachse album bleibt stabil und hoch
wenn sie das niveau ausgeht von der
kraft her gehe einen kleinen schritt
näher hin dann haben wir viel weniger
zug drauf dann kann ich die position
wieder stabil und sicher halten sei es
durch 30 sekunden sind vorbei übung
nummer vier
wir gehen in die tiefe position das
heißt auch für euch zuhause kurz umbauen
dass der bank wieder auf bodenhöhe
einhängen weil wir starten wieder mit
dem rudern position finden richtigen zug
einstellen
fünf sekunden und dann legen wir wieder
los 21 arbeitszeit für euch zuhause 30
sekunden geht los auch hier achtet
darauf rücken stabil rücken gerade dazu
kommt nur in dem verständlich vor der
ellbogen zieht nach hinten
der rest bleibt stabil und ohne bewegung
braucht eine gewisse grundspannung noch
521 30 sekunden sind wir durch
seit band das heißt bauchmuskulatur
seitlich richtet euch ein aufstehen
oberkörper ist aufrecht ausgangsposition
und kippt zur seite das heißt die
seitlichen bauchmuskulatur ist die die
man da ist der belasten
taxifahrer vor niki dass die leute das
name wissen zu hause gerade position und
wir kippen zur seite und haben den zug
drinnen das war eigentlich seitlichen
bauchmuskulatur scheider 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit genau das was an beweglichen
ist ohne dass ich mich vertreten muss
oder verbiegen muss das tut sie und da
arbeite ich und noch 321 sei es durch
seite wechseln ausgangsposition gesetzes
ist gerade und aus dieser position
heraus sich auf die seite hinein sodass
in der bauchmuskulatur anzug spürt in
fünf sekunden statt bloss noch 321 und
läuft auch hier schulter bleiben tief
die fahnder nicht nach oben die bleiben
unten körper ist stabil und da können
sie sich vorstellen als wenn sich ohne
das jetzt abkriegt in der hüfte mit der
hand übers knie hinunter zieht aber
können sich nicht in der hüfte knicken
jetzt ziehen sie konnten
zeit ist das was man als nächstes mal
ein guter job genau das heißt das
verkehrte holzhacken die belastung kommt
in dem fall von unten nach oben da ist
viel mehr spannung ein bisschen mehr zug
auf dem theraband drauf und das schöne
rotation belastung wo er meint natürlich
entsprechend aber in einer rotation
belasten muss muskulär abgesichert dann
ist das alles kein problem
zehn sekunden arbeit durch probieren
aber ausprobieren
pastor widerstand ist zu viel ist zu
wenig bereit machen drei sekunden und
dann legen wir los zeit läuft aus der
geraden position nach unten gehen genau
und hochdrehen hoch rotieren da bauch
und den rücken vier unter voll spannung
die arbeiten auf hochtouren
im zehn sekunden ist schon wieder vorbei
dann haben wir die 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit an schon wieder erledigt und
wechseln an die seite kurz aus locker 30
sekunden seien nicht länger bereit
machen auch immer wieder
zwischendrin ein facharzt mal probieren
passt man die spannung und wenig glaubt
die spannung ist in ordnung dann kann
ich gleich wieder mit arbeiten beginnen
das heißt wir fahren am besten im 21 und
jetzt zweiter durchgang holzhacken
verkehrt herum
niki folgt jetzt die geste holzhacken
magst du das bist du eine weitere also
immer auch dies in meiner freizeit total
gern bin ich total viel und oft ein wort
und duda holz hacken und holzarbeiten
mit der hand und motorsäge und das ist
für mich ein perfekter ausgleich kannst
vielleicht einmal probieren also mir das
recht aus lockern entspannen letzte
übung kreuzheben oder good morning je
nachdem nehme ich das bein in einem
winkel mit dann bin ich eher im
kreuzheben drin
lass ich die beine gestreckt dann habe
ich allerdings das heißt unteren rücken
ist in beiden fällen mit dabei
dieser feine dazu armen und dann was das
geschoss 30 sie konnten gut in die
aufrichtung arbeiten stabile position
ich weiß ich wiederhole mich aber das
kann man nicht oft genug sagen so dass
hier zu hause einfach entsprechend gut
vorbereitet trainieren kennt und
entsprechend beim training immer wieder
die kontrolle haben damit nichts
passiert sie keiner verletzt oder wehtut
soll die letzten sekunden unseres
workshops sind angebrochen noch 32 12
mal zehn übungen sommer durch danke
meinen dank nicht vorzeigen das mit
trainieren
ich hoffe ihr habt ein bisschen was
mitnehmen können für zuhause in
habscheid mit trainiert wir dann morgen
wieder für euch da
mit dem nächsten workout und wir freuen
uns auf euch ich wünsche euch noch einen
schönen tag